good morning everyone can everyone hear
me okay yes thank you
and so my name is cosmos Pavan che I am
the PI IDs organizer in Montreal and I
also lead a data science team in a
company called Shopify and today I want
to convince you that biases are bugs and
that we need to find them and learn from
them so by a show of hands here how many
of you have ever trained a machine
learning algorithm at work in your life
at school that's pretty much like almost
all the rules which is pretty amazing
because you are the frontline you are
the people that are working with the
algorithm so you have the most impact on
how they behave and we already heard
today to talk around the same subject so
by now you should probably understand
how machine learning algorithms can be
biased because the cool thing about
machine learning is that you don't have
to write and code yourself the rules of
the algorithm the algorithm learns it
directly from data the thing is that
this data is oftentimes generated by
humans and humans and you know they have
stereotypes we have biases they
sometimes and it discriminates towards
each other so at this type of thing ends
up in your algorithm anyway so my first
point is that algorithms learn biases
from data and just to illustrate this I
would like to show this example it's
inspired by a Katherine John wolf talk
at them well she did a keynote at by
disaster down a few months ago so in
Google Translate you can translate
obviously I have phrases from a language
to another and the cool thing about a
Turkish is that it's a genderless
language meaning that there's no he or
she pronounces the same pronouns for all
genders so if you take a sentence like
she's a physicist he's a nurse
translated to Turkish and then
translated back all of a sudden
is a physicist and she is a nurse right
and nobody at Google told the algorithm
there's a lot more men in physics than
women and I know because I have a PhD in
physics and I can tell you there's not a
lot of women in those departments it's
just that the algorithm learned it from
the data so the bias is there in the
data and it can end up in your algorithm
so this is just Google Translate but
imagine other algorithms that open door
for people like metaphorical doors I
know having a loan from your bank
getting accepted into college or being
arrested or not by the police this type
of things are very important to be as
free of discrimination as possible
so in this talk I will talk about
detecting biases in algorithms removing
those biases from algorithms and making
it work in your organization and the
last point is less about coding and more
about people because if you spend any
time coding as a professional you know
that it's not always about the technical
stuff it's also about making it work
with your team with your company or your
organization so let's talk about three
strategies to detect biases and
algorithms the first one I want to talk
about I call it stress cases and it's a
term that I borrowed from the user
experience community and designers
talked a lot about well there's this
movement for designing with empathy so a
stress case is something that you might
call an edge case except that when you
call it an edge case it's something that
you know it doesn't matter it's an edge
case it's it's so fringe and it will you
know it's not like mine names we think
that will happen the most often so I
won't really look at it well if you call
it a stress case it's like okay there's
this thing that can happen and it's
really bad and I want to address it so
it's basically designed for the worst
case scenario and a lot of people have
given talks about this in the context of
user
experience I really enjoyed us aha what
sir butcher and Doc and look her up on
TED talks she's awesome
and also her book and so an example like
if you're working on a face recognition
algorithm what's the worst thing that
can happen
maybe not recognize her face which is
something that happened and this is a
joy bulam Winnie as she's a grad student
at MIT and she's developing applications
that use the face recognition software
that is of the shelf that is open source
and she has trouble coding her things
because it doesn't recognize her face or
skin tone is too dark for the algorithm
so she codes with a white mask on this
is a very bad user experience in my
opinion and so she she started something
called the algorithmic justice league so
you can check it out where she thoughts
about her experience with this and so
stress cases the pros I think it's
really about anticipating the problems
that are hard to quantify I'll talk a
little bit later about like things that
you can quantify but things like oh you
know what's the worst that can happen
like my image Tigers dying could be
tagging people as animals like this
would be bad and it's hard to quantify
so it's really good to make you think
about what your algorithm will do the
problem is that of course you will never
catch all those edge cases so it's not
exactly scalable and it's not systematic
either so let's talk about another
approach that is a little bit more
scalable and a little bit more
systematic and that would be to use an
association test package so what is it
so your algorithm is this black box it
has inputs it all that output and you
can run an association test
in parallel so it will take as input the
input and output from your algorithm and
also maybe add other things if there
were not already in your input such as
gender race or their protected class
attributes and when I talk about
protected class attributes I mean age
gender sexual orientation age there are
those things that those you know
dimensions of diversity that we don't
want to discriminate against and it
provides you a bug report and I feel
that this is really powerful to treat
you know discrimination as bugs in your
algorithms and yes so Association matrix
might be things like in a correlation
coefficient or a normalized mutual
information between your variables and
since we're at the Python conference I
want to give a shout out to this Python
package that I used
it's called Erica's you can find it on
github there's a whole paper about it
but it's really about this you just give
it you know a panda's data frame and it
will like look at all the different
features and though in this fatwa of the
different columns in your panda's data
frame and find associations between
those columns and the outcome and the
outcome being like getting alone or not
getting alone are getting into college
not getting college getting arrested not
getting arrested so the pros as we love
multiple Association matrix you can
there's also statistical significance in
there which is very important and you
can also add it to an automated workflow
which is wonderful because in the kind
of work that I do I when I put a machine
learning algorithm in production it just
runs all the time and I can just be
monitoring it myself
always so it's nice to have this thing
that is monitoring my actual pipeline
in the current section I assume it
assumes that we have the protected class
attributes so in the previous talk that
that we saw today in the data there was
already the race
there I work in a while I'd ratify it's
mostly an e-commerce platform and I
don't ask the gender from the merchants
that we ever have the app developers and
that sort of thing I don't have so I can
infer it in other ways so let's say that
they gave us their first name I can use
another package to infer their gender
from their first name for instance but
this is not perfect so as Andrea's was
saying before it would be nice to have
all those you know dimensions of
diversity that we care about you know
that we don't want to discriminate
against so that we can make sure that
our algorithms are you know acting
fairly on the other hand and we need to
be transparent about that with the
people that we're getting this
information from and also it doesn't
have any agreed-upon trishal so if I
find that my algorithm says oh there's a
association between a gender and the
positive outcome of 0.05
you know normalized mutual information
like is that good or is that bad I don't
know this this kind of thing will come
with experience and I have the freedom
to figure out the threshold myself but
it would be nice to have also some kind
of agreed upon threshold so for an
agreed upon threshold we can talk about
this this part and practices Andrea
talked a little bit about before so it's
basically yes you take the probability
of the positive outcomes from for the
minority group and for the majority
group and what you want to do is like
when you have this ratio you want it to
be as close as possible to 1 right
because I give the two probabilities are
equal than the ratio with this one and
in the US law there's this 80% rule
which would actually place the threshold
point eight so if you're between point
eight and one then you're not
discriminatory so this is super easy to
compute when you have all the
ingredients together you just need a
confusion matrix like that and it's a
super super easy formula to compute so
it's very straightforward and it's being
on a grid concepts which is a lot and so
at least when you have a conversation
with your colleagues like where you
should put the threshold this is you
know the law is a good reference at
least a good starting point again it
does so but this does not explicitly
take into account statistical
significance and I run into this problem
when I was looking at groups that were
really small and so it's something that
you have to think about I'm not worried
because I know that your data scientists
and you know how to do statistical
significance and I just like remember to
do them and yeah and also it I think
that we have the protected class
attribute which is in my case is always
a problem because I don't have it in my
own data set now I talked about three
strategies to remove the biases from the
algorithm in this case a good strategy
might be to get more data and that's
exactly what the algorithm the algorithm
justice league is seeking to do so one
way that we can have you know open
source base recognition packages to work
is to have a beta with you know the
faces of people with all skin colors to
make sure that we're training on a
larger more diverse data set so that it
actually works so if you want to
participate in this project this visit
our website and the second thing that we
can do is tweak the features the hard
thing about machine learning is not the
machine learning algorithm itself you
just like import scikit-learn and you're
pretty much done
the real work that we do every day is
treat well choosing the future
engineering the future thinking about
like which feature we should have in our
algorithm which one we should exclude
and you know if you know what's the
output that you want and if you know the
way that you want our algorithm to
behave you can treat your features until
it is the way you want I know I'm
referring a lot to Andrea stock before
but I'm really excited about it I think
it was a really great way to show how to
do that in in reality and the third one
I want to talk about I have actually two
examples of this and it's deficit repair
so if you have a feature that you know
is biased you can modify it to like
repair your debt of it so in this case
and you know this is a ECT score so the
ASIS SAT test is a test that people take
in the US and the highest you score it
opens doors to the you know the Ivy
League universities and the good
universities we want to go so this is a
very high pressure test and it highly
currently with other things like gender
or race or linear social economical
status because some people you know they
take you know prep prep schools are
basically for performance performing
well on a CT score so if you know that
two different groups don't perform in
the same way you have to correct for it
in order to be able to use this feature
in your algorithm and so let's take two
hypothetical groups and one is the red
curve one is the blue curve and what we
want to do is to just correct them so
that they meet somewhere in the middle I
found the black curve and one way you
could do that is to take our
distribution chop it up into percentiles
and apply a transformation to remap it
to
you know the one and same distribution
for everyone and the very interesting
thing with this is that you can go from
zero repair to a hundred percent repair
and everywhere in between
that spectrum so and also you probably
are thinking but if we change the data
it should change the performance of the
algorithm right and and you are right
but the cool thing is that we can look
at the performance of the algorithm as a
function of the amount of repair that we
do and I took this example from a paper
certifying and removing disparate impact
and this is what they dick done for many
data sets um and basically you go from
the red regions are the regions where
the disparate impact is below 0.8 so if
you were to you know just go to a court
of law in the US like you could have a
case for a discrimination and you take
you know you go from that red zone to
the green zone between 0.8 and 1 by just
tweaking this data set repair just by
treating the amount of repair for your
features and yes the performance of the
algorithms goes down sometimes it goes
down by 1% and like are you willing to
trade 1% of your algorithm performance
to go from an algorithm that is
discriminatory to an algorithm that is
fair I think it's a good question to ask
ourselves my own answer would be yes but
I invite you to think about it and in my
second example of deficit repair is with
word endings because the other example
that I just showed is just like a it's
just like one number right and you have
a distribution and it's easy what do you
do with words and buildings right so
we're Tyvek is one of those word
embedding it is basically a mathematical
geometrical space where you have a bunch
of words and
and so you can have vectors between
words and those vectors encode
relationship between words so if you
have the vector between man and King and
then take a sign vector and put it side
to 2,000 women it points to Queen so you
can see things like man is - King what
woman is - Queen and this is perfect
because this is exactly it right let's
try with other words man is to lie and
what woman is to lie on it this is
perfectly fine is the feminine form of
Zion man is to surgeon what women is to
nurse there's a little bit of a thorough
thorough back there
computer have managed to computer
programmer what woman is - homemaker
this is pretty terrible I know that we
live in a society where there are more
men in the tech industry and more women
that are you know at home and raising
children but I mean I'm a computer
programmer I know a lot of women that
are computer programmer and this is not
necessarily the world where I want to
live where computers are also sexist
basically and this is the problem if you
use this kind of word and bidding in an
application that say is you know ranking
people for jobs you know if you want to
if you're if I want to show you like
what's the most relevant job for you and
I know you're a woman I might not I give
you you know the high paying jobs or the
tech jobs so we need to be very careful
especially when when you take word
embeddings that you have not trained
yourself or that you're not exactly sure
what the data that gets into it just
make sure that you look at those kind of
things before applying them okay we know
our words vac am bidding
by us what can we do to unbias it and
remember what I said earlier that you
know were Tuvok is just this geometrical
space that means that we can rotate if
we can apply transformation on it so we
can you know warp it in a way that we
minimize these biases and that's exactly
what the authors did and this is a paper
that was a highlighter that nips last
December I think and they went from you
know this bias for them getting to much
less biased and being but the thing is
that this takes time and effort right
their methodology was to show pairs of
word and ask people if those words are
you know stereotypes are not stereotypes
and you know it takes money to do that
it takes time to do that it says you
know make any cultures or your friends
or whatever you it it takes a lot of
effort to do this type of thing so I
wanted to show you those two very
different examples to show you that it
is possible good it takes time and
effort
well strategies to make this work in
your organization so I work at Shopify
I'm using a data team there and I want
to make sure that the algorithms we put
out into the world are behaving in a way
that is in line with the world we want
to see which is not with discrimination
of course so my first tip is to leverage
the existing culture in your
organization so what does that mean for
me for the whole hiring process our
tenant acquisition people you know they
give us a lot of advice on unconscious
bias on diversity of thought and you
know all those things because we want to
hire a diverse pool of people so we
already have all those
word in our vocabulary is already part
of our culture look so if I say if I go
to my colleague and say yeah you know
how like humans can be unconsciously
biased if you thought that algorithms
can also be unconsciously biased that
they understand what I'm talking about
from our legal team we have a code of
conduct which actually boils down to a
handful and very a very simple questions
we can ask ourselves to make sure that
we're behaving in a way that is okay
with our colleagues or with the company
or with our clients so how about having
a code of conduct parallel algorithms
and also we have a strong engineering
culture so if you tell me that my code
as bugs I want to fix it so if you tell
me that biases are bugs I surely want to
fix it and also part of the engineering
culture is also having a code reviews
and in those code reviews we have a
checklist of things to check like you're
not going to ship code without checking
if you have a real number security
vulnerabilities in it you should not
also ship algorithms that have you know
that that have biases at them so we
could actually piggyback on that kind of
process to make it more systematic
treating a machine learning code of
conduct we created one and how we did it
we assembled a diverse team we had
someone from select acquisition to talk
about inclusion and diversity and
unconscious bias someone from designs
who talked about how you know how to
design with empathy thinking about those
stress cases we had also of course data
scientists that write machine learning
algorithms and also someone that's
really interested in data privacy and we
all got together and in two days we
discussed and debated ideas and we made
a shortlist of questions that we st. and
compass' you know that creates kind of a
good code of conduct and then you have
to use it for real because we will find
that you have blind spots and
you have to repeat repeat and do it over
again because technology will change
laws will change your the way you think
about those things will change so it's
it's fine to - to change it over time so
this is actually the Shopify and
ecolution earning code of conduct first
thing we ask is it fair is it illegal
and those are pretty huge reason like
why we asked them would it be okay if it
were publicized if you're not okay with
a being publicized it's probably too
shady to be doing anyway so don't do it
what's the most horrible case that can
happen and what am i doing to avoid this
this directly relates the stress case
that I saw before is the person I'm
collecting data from directly benefiting
from it we're trying not to collect data
that we won't use to make people's lives
better
so am I mistaken correlation for
causation is not that much associated
with machine learning but more like our
good data code of conduct in general and
on this so that was more on the ethics
side of things on the engineering side
of things we want to strive for
authenticity if something goes wrong can
I trace back exactly which version of
the algorithm which version of the
training data set was used algorithm
furnace which we talked about already a
lot continuous improvement is like will
we you know when we we find that there's
a bad behavior from the machine learning
algorithm you know we will continuously
improve it until it works in the way we
want and interpretability we should be
you know able to understand why an
algorithm made a decision and last but
not least get everyone on board talk
with the other data scientist in your
organization but also talk about these
things more widely so that people
understand what you're trying to do with
this and so if you're like lightning
thoughts inside your company do it too
to tell people and also get the exact
buy-in because for two reasons
there's a first reason would be it takes
time and resources to have great fare
algorithms right so if you're going to
take you a bit more time and get more
resources to do your work your bus
should be on your side and the other
thing is that you know there's there
might be a trade-off between fairness
and something else and that's something
else could be profit for the company and
you want to make sure that if there's a
spectrum between profit and fairness
that people are on board with it
so I spoke directly to the CEO about
this and this is what they told me if
you can tweak a dial between the trade
offs of fairness and process turn it
strongly towards fairness so this is
really great because it tells me as a
data scientist that I have an
environment where I can actually do my
work properly and make sure that my
algorithms are not biased so to conclude
I hope that I've convinced you that
biases are bugs I need to be found six
and lurtz
learned from thank you very much for
your attention
Thank You France laws and we're open for
questions we have quite some time and
thank you right there on the back ah
you'll get it go ahead yes thanks for
spectacular presentation I had a
question with the dataset repair part so
when you were remapping the distribution
from what answered those were remapping
z' of the features could you go to that
could you explain that with an example
maybe with an example well okay so this
is the something I've done myself six
and this is a paper called certifying
and removing disparate impact so so your
question is do to have an example so how
does it work
so Playa so is let's say that you you
have two distributions that you want to
to remap together we take those
distributions and then you bend them
into a percentile so maybe like a
hundred bins and then for each of those
bin you find what is the transformation
to you know what let's say that the
factor you should multiply it with so
that it gets to the the black
distribution that is a common
distribution for the other two so but in
that case in this hypothetical example
let's say that the red population know
on average gets worse SAT scores the
blue population on average gets better
SAT scores what we're saying is that at
a so di di use case here I suppose is a
hiring use case or so bad that that you
should hire equally from both
populations yeah so so I kind of ignored
the underlying data yes so the okay so
this is a good idea to do this when you
know that the the data set that you're
trying to repair is because of a
discrimination issue are a bias issue so
what you're doing is you're you're
correcting for this bias you know just
as a you know the IQ score
right i IQ correlates with a lot of
things it's super cultural but when you
state I choose cars or people it's
usually like corrected for I don't know
other dimensions of diversity here is
just like basically if this was IQ
scores it's like how do you correct for
those diversity aspects so basically
what you're saying here is that the ACC
score is not representative of how of
how smart people are it's representative
of how smart people are and their gender
and their race and you just want to
minimize the effects of race or gender
or other attributes you've got it
so there's an underlying hypothesis that
the mean is the same and therefore you
can do it quickly
exactly all right next question hello
fan TAS first here in the front so first
of all want to congratulate you on the
code of conduct I think it's super
awesome
so I'm wondering first of all like how
it came into being if it was all some
practical problems you came to and then
try to deal with them and some
formulated some process and out of that
some some kind of close contact game or
so how this came to be and the other one
also just one questions with one
question okay so that's the question
came to me it's a very good question
thanks for that question so um so I
think that it's just you know we see in
the media all those problems with
algorithms not being fair and also we
realize that we are starting to create
algorithms inside the company that open
door for people and it was just this
communal sense of okay we need to think
about this before it becomes a problem
because like well you know a couple of
months ago we knew that okay we have
this algorithm but we don't know if it's
fair enough
how are we going to get there like well
like me and and actually what happened
is that
every so we have a lot of data team at
certify we are about like over a hundred
people in the data organization itself
and there's a lot of things doing a lot
of there's a lot of teams doing their
own thing and the idea is to you know
just open this forum so that we can have
this conversation because like oh like
you did this in your algorithm and and
you took those steps to make sure that
it was a good idea to deploy this
algorithm and I did this let's talk
about this and let's try to figure out a
more unified way to think about those
issues from the engineering perspective
and from the ethical perspective so
there was no you know chester RC r PR
catastrophe that happened it's more
about okay let's talk about those things
before they become a problem because
it's just like everyone I hears about it
in the news and we just want it to be
proactive about this all right next
question right over there I thank you
for this really nice talk so I was
wondering also during the first talk
already so most of the examples were
kind of assuming that there is one
specific attribute you look at right so
for example gender but often I mean it
might be the case that not all women are
discriminated but maybe women that have
kids but no partner right so it's a
combination of several attributes so I'm
kind of wondering these methods which
you suggested like this fear test
package or other things I mean are they
taking care of that or are we simply
looking at correlations and then try to
make sense out of whether you know one
group is kind of discriminated but just
based on one attribute this is a really
good question and also for the fair test
package the really nice thing is that
it's slicing and dicing by all subgroups
so let's say that you have both gender
and ethnicity it will take all the
combinations of gender and ethnicity and
find the ones that have associations
between that group and the positive
outcome and if it's statistically
significant
basically significant it will give you
it will tell you in a body part and this
is very powerful because in the examples
that come with the package you can see
that okay well for you know black people
under forty five years old or whatever
it like you you can get like pretty
pretty precise with that so that's takes
care of it and also in this paper
certifying and removing disparate impact
say this they did this repair for just
like one variable which in this case I
think it was gender but you can also do
it with multiple variables because that
in the specific case that they were
investigating I controlling for gender
and race at the same time was not you
know didn't have like a huge influence
because in this case it was only like
one attribute that was bigger than the
other but definitely looking at
combinations of attributes is is also
something we should do thanks for the
question all right one more over here
it's a nice purse district perspective I
think like if you use some kind of and
simple methods like boosting which
promises to reduce biases search and
variance so are we good to go
I mean should we like take a special
interest or attention that we should
reduce bias because those algorithm
straight out of the box promise to do
that yeah a promise to do that but I
mean you should always be be careful
right like that so so let's say I would
say that we wished it all you know
always think about that stress case
always think yeah I I don't think that
there's a wonderful algorithm that will
you know not be biased because the bias
is in the data so my answer will be
still be on the lookout for for those
for discrimination
or any more questions for common how do
you find the features that you don't
want to correct for let's say the blue
line represents students with a straight
A in high school and the red line with C
and below so you don't want to correct
for that I guess actually so how do you
how do you find these features a very
good question so in the in the law I
guess it depends on the country where
you are but say yeah you know there's
something that's called the protected
class attributes and so there's laws
that you cannot discriminate against age
gender race and there's a whole list of
them so I would say these are the ones
that are important to look for and
because of course if you're looking at
like should you get into college and you
look at the straight A's and this is of
course it would look like that so I
would say that looking at what the law
tells us about this is a good start but
of course it's a using your your human
judgement for those things so if I go
back here is it fair and is it legal
you know like getting more straight-a
students into college I think it's fair
because it's you know they work for it
you might have a different opinion but I
would start with the the law the
protected class attributes and then go
from there with that kind of question
all right well thank you very much and
could I have another round of applause
or on five
[Applause]